the next generation of Call of Duty has  been revealed Infinity Ward is back at  the helm and Activision has released the  first trailer I'm Tony this is a game  spot news update and this is call of  duty infinite warfare as expected a good  chunk of the game will take place in  space as you become captain of your own  warship and battle the settlement  defense force Activision says infinite  warfare story is front and center with a  focus on leadership and responsibility  and of course you'll be getting new  environments new weapons and new  abilities the fights will take place on  the ground in the air and outside of the  atmosphere Call of Duty infinite warfare  launches for ps4 xbox one and pc on  november fourth it'll be available in  standard digital deluxe legacy and  legacy Pro Edition and every special  edition includes call of duty modern  warfare remastered for more on that  remake infinite warfare or call of duty  in general keep it locked to gamespot